foreign
you'll hear Darth Vader
yeah that's a bad Darth Vader sorry
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
Chuck co-host always good to have you
man always a pleasure to be here yeah
this one I figured Let's do an homage to
going back to school all right okay why
not so this is the back to school
edition not only people were actually
going back to school but people who
might I don't know how many out there
feel this way who might look
nostalgically on having been in school
where your only job in life was to learn
yes yeah that's a thing you know so the
two to the two of you out there the two
people because everyone else is a fan of
of Alice Cooper schools out oh summer
yes schools
yeah those folks well he lied he's lied
because school is never out that's what
people don't know
there's still a level of curiosity in
you in you so that you can become a
lifelong learner I disagree I disagree
you are a lifelong learner whether you
want to be or not it just depends on how
you want to learn no I met some ossified
people they ain't learning a damn thing
so don't tell me that yeah well no it's
like no they're learning the hard way
the hard way that's all so for this back
to school edition we're we're expanding
our reach going to our Tick Tock
following and our what Twitter following
yeah okay yeah I guess so so they might
become patreon members one day so we'll
uh we'll reach there and well you know
what give a taste of what's otherwise
behind the the you know protected space
right so if you want to go to
patreon.com StarTalk and you can support
us and then you will receive what we're
doing right now as a Command Performance
a private show just for you where Neil
answers all all of our patreon patrons
questions
so but this time we're extending it to
anybody on Tick Tock and Instagram of
our fan base in those platforms yes yes
everybody gets everybody gets one free
okay plus you're not supposed to ask for
money before we did anything for them so
you gotta like we gotta do the show see
that's then
you're speaking like a person who has
confidence
I I like to get the money up front up
front I got you okay up front let's go
so what do you have all right here we go
but what's in response to we solicited
the questions with a it was is there
anything you wished you had learned in
school or want to still learn was it
didn't we yeah we pose that question
okay basically yeah there we go anything
you wish you had learned want to still
learn or just maybe curious about now
yeah let's do it so here we go uh this
is travel for real from tick tock and
travel for real says uh by the way his
name is Josh he says uh uh is there any
scientific evidence
for what happens before or after this
life
uh oh yes uh-huh yes well in the sense
that everything we know about who you
are as an individual
everything emanates from the
electrochemical phenomena in your brain
and we know this because people who get
a series of mini strokes little bits of
them begin to go away the first you know
kinetically with their muscles but also
in their mind and and so they slowly go
away then whoever you remember to be
there bit by bit is being disassembled
by the loss of electrochemical
um synaptic functions in the brain right
and so you get to a point where a person
totally Strokes out and their body might
even still be alive the rest of their
body but you you they don't function
their the pupils don't dilate or
constrict they they're brain dead
basically at that point but the very
deep part of the brain that keeps the
body alive 5 the body is still doing
what it's doing okay so so
as far as we know when you die
since all other neurosynaptic phenomena
cease
you enter a state of non-existence
okay period and is that any different
from your state of non-existence
that
was before you were born
Chuck before you were born you know 10
years before you're born you're not
saying where am I how come I'm not into
the world
so you you don't you're not lamenting
your state of non-existence before you
were born
and all evidence points that after you
die you re-enter a state of
non-existence it's that simple
and uh so people by the way there are
many people who don't like that answer
no they don't that's what science tells
us but they don't like the answer they
need there to be things after you die
Paradise
Paradise of any kind described in
multiple religions yes and and if you're
into reincarnation you will believe you
were a life form before your current one
so so so
their belief systems out there that say
all kinds of things about before you're
born and after you die but if you're
going to ask a scientist that's the
answer you're going to get so what that
tells me is as a scientist that I have
to make this life count
because there's not one that's after it
this life is more than just a read
through which is the Chili Peppers way
of saying it oh the real read through
it's interesting that's right yeah Power
and agency over your Ambitions your
goals where you land where you launch
from this ain't no rehearsal baby yep
that's it this is the one and the only
make it count all right keep it going oh
by the way there's a whole chapter in my
next book which is called Starry
Messenger but there's an entire chapter
on life and death where all these topics
are addressed in case you want to read
up on them even further yes if you want
to be more depressed than you are now
that's right
yeah so there you go all right that's
very cool and Josh says this
okay I'm just reading them and I don't
judge he says you kind of are just I'm
saying but go on it's okay all right
okay go yeah you called me out all right
what was first dinosaur
or water
or trees
and did the comet really take out the
dinosaurs okay all right so water
yeah water was there from the beginning
of things in space it's space water is
in space so we got we got water water is
a yeah is a comet it's because hydrogen
and oxygen are both common in the
universe so putting them together to
make H2O you got that one for free all
right okay next came trees
then came dinosaurs right in in that
order and the cool part is there's a
time when we had trees but no no
microbes to digest the wood
so a tree would grow fall over and die
and there would be nothing for it to
decompose we are so accustomed to seeing
a a Fallen Tree in the forest that is
crumbling back to soil in the presence
of microbes and insects and and if it's
old enough you can take your hand and
just crush it crush it crush it into
dust okay how strong I am
that did not happen uh there's a point
when that did not happen all the trees
accumulated and there's an entire layer
in the geologic strata called the
Carboniferous era where all the trees
and other vegetation collapsed and did
not decompose wow and out of that
Carboniferous error we get our coal and
oil right there it is and that's why
yeah and everybody says this though I'm
glad you just said this out of the
carbon in the first era we get coal and
oil because uh fossil fuels
uh means buried it doesn't mean dinosaur
oh right right yeah in fact the oil we
you know we used to think that there was
an ad for for uh what's the the the oil
company that used a brontosaurus who was
a Sinclair so Sinclair had a
brontosaurus and I think one of their
commercials implied that all the oil
came from dead dinosaurs but it's mostly
from vegetation from vegetation that
never decomposed right in the in the
usual way gets buried in under long
times of pressure and temperature
there's a chemical change that boosts it
with the kind of energy you want for an
industrialized civilization
there you go yeah oh by the way and and
dinosaurs they're still around they're
called Birds that's true right yeah okay
that's very and you know uh yeah then uh
that's the I didn't see it but I hear
that's the whole big reveal in the
latest Jurassic Park is that the
dinosaurs have feathers
oh okay yeah and that would be the trend
the the likely link between the modern
day birds and what they were right
that's right but by the way trees are
not the oldest things around there are
other sort of vertebrate life forms that
predate trees so just so sharks are
older than trees for example so yeah so
uh so anyhow it says fascinating the
history of life on Earth uh and who came
first and who didn't uh here's one for
you you ready we all don't we all nobody
doesn't love stegosaurus right of course
okay it looks like his own castle yes or
his own uh armor his own armor yeah yeah
yeah so stegosaurus and so
we are so stegosaurus predates T-Rex
okay by how much but I don't know more
than T-Rex predates us oh my goodness
right so stegosaurus is like the old man
of the dinosaur Stegosaurus is the OG
all right
so we so we are closer in in time to
T-Rex than T-Rexes to the stegosaurus I
thought I'd throw that out there let's
show some respect T-Rex that's right you
don't know you mess with stegosaurus
that's that's kind of dope that's
totally the OG of dinosaurs you know
that I did not know that that's a long
time that's a that that's a long time
okay and you know and you know what
upset me right when we did more
calculations with the stability of
Saturn's rings which is just a swarm of
particles in orbit not entirely stable
that there was some talk that the
Saturn's rings were only around for
maybe 50 million years at most 100
million years
so there's a chance that if the
dinosaurs had a telescope and they
looked up at Saturn they would see no
ring at all wow yeah and that's what he
said that'd be sad for me if I was a
dinosaur because I love Saturn yeah it
was it was probably sadder for T-Rex
because uh his arms are too short to try
and use a telescope okay arms are too
short for everything it's just like you
know
why can't I get this
all right yo that's okay very cool very
cool very cool let's go to lenscape Via
Tick Tock oh
all right landscape just wants to jump
into like a whole bath of goodness all
at once let's do that Neil
are we living in a simulation
I I am not as convinced as other people
are
and uh again I hate to sound like a a
broken record but in my book I give an
argument I call it the inanity defense
for why we're not a simulation
okay because every computer we've ever
programmed
to do any task at all is vastly more
logical than we have ever been
vastly more sensible vastly more
traceable in the causes and effects of
what it does
so
if we're a simulation someone would have
to program the computer
for its characters to make completely
irrational stupid decisions that we make
every day of our lives and who would do
that that's all I'm saying so I'm
thinking a simulated Universe all of its
life forms would be way more logical and
rational than any evidence humans have
ever given
for behaving that way so that's what
that's where I'm coming from here I call
it the inanity defense right but here's
the thing
the the the
inanity is is far more interesting so if
you're a designer why wouldn't you do
that
yeah but you wouldn't need to do it to
this depth I mean you can throw in a few
irrational players right and everybody's
got to deal with them yeah but at the
extent the breadth and the depth of
which it appears clearly no computer was
involved that's all I gotta say yeah
okay I got you yeah okay it's like
there's crazy and then there's us
that's basically what what it comes down
to
no computer could be this before they
can't they got silicon chips that that
have you know logical circuitry right so
there you go all right very cool all
right bro give me another one
here we go this is a
Seth Pasquale says this uh 25 Seth
Pasquale's 25. what sound does space
make if you were to float around in it
oh so in other words what would you hear
if you're in the nothingness of space
gotcha and we will get to that when we
come back from our break all right uh
first segment over when we come back
more Cosmic queries back to school
edition everything you thought you
should have learned in school or you
wanted to learn in school when StarTalk
returns
we're back Cosmic query is opened up to
other branches of our fan base maybe
they'll become patreon members too but
so we left off with a question Chuck
what was it and who and who who asked it
uh yes this was Seth Pasquale 25. and he
says from from what from tick tock tick
tock okay and he says what sound does
space make if you were to float around
in it what do you hear if you're just
out in the nothingness of space
foreign
ER
that's a bad Darth Vader sorry uh you'll
you'll hear nothing there's no medium to
communicate sound from any place in
space to your ears so what you'll begin
to hear are things inside your body
right so I was in the quietest place on
Earth
and it is a room at Bell Telephone
Laboratories in Murray Hill New Jersey
and every bit of sound
that would be exterior to the room
doesn't get in and any sound that you
make gets completely deadened against
the walls you're not even standing on a
floor you're standing on a mesh that is
equidistant between a ceiling and a
floor then the floor below you which is
also made of specially designed acoustic
materials so I'm standing in there and
you don't hear anything
you don't hear anything and I started
hearing blood pumping through my ear
canal
wow yeah are you sure you weren't having
a stroke no I hope being from New York
and for the first time hearing
absolutely nothing your brain just
couldn't take your body freaked out your
brain started to explode or implode yeah
so at the so at the end of the day allow
me to say there is no such thing as The
Sound of Silence
other than blood moving within your
skull oh man Simon and Garfunkel hates
you right oh yeah yeah yeah I don't know
there you go so you hear you hear
yourself wait wait just wait just to be
more poetic just to end that more
poetically another way to say it is the
sound of silence is the sound of things
that were always making noise that you
never noticed before
how about that look at that far more
profound yeah yeah exactly so in other
words uh you need to Miyagi this and
listen to yourself a little closer okay
and one other thing
there's a saying attributed to Nietzsche
okay and this I quote in the book too
damn my life just is the book no right
now it is it's those who were dancing
were deemed insane by those who could
not hear the music there you go
and just think about if you watch people
behind a glass screen dancing and you
can't hear the music they're they're
they're crazy people they look insane
right they look insane they're jumping
up and down wailing they're flailing
their arms and legs so I think there's a
lot in that quote in terms of what is
the reality that you experience versus
that of others and what is it that you
define as
that which is objectively true
and be and always think twice before you
pass Judgment of what you see others
doing maybe it's because they hear the
music and you do not right
all right here we go uh this is zamarian
from Tick Tock zalmarian says
how do you think our star really is is
it possible
that it's older than we think is it okay
I mean is it lying about its age I mean
it's our soul our star going like you
know the sun is telling us how old it is
and Chuck right it could be lying I
don't know the issues with stars but if
they have social issues that where this
matters most stars most stars lie about
the age
so all all the evidence we have tells us
that our stars are about four and a half
to 4.6 billion years old slightly older
than Earth's Moon itself so and we
expect it to live another five billion
years in good health there you go before
it expands and then engulfs the orbits
of Mercury Venus and Earth uh vaporizing
the oceans and then the atmosphere and
then all Life as We Know It
so have a nice day there you go
and that's our show people
sleep well sleep well there you go all
right that's very cool so now how old is
the earth if the
4.55 yeah 4.55 we all
everything kind of coalesced in that
time right exactly so you can ask uh
what are the chances of that being wrong
I suppose there's a chance but has so
much supporting evidence that we're on
to the next questions no longer even
judging whether those estimates are
false a little further because they're
so successful that's right God there you
go all right here's the little toenail
okay that's the name of a user okay
that's a little toenail from Tick Tock
all right you gotta love that
okay here's the deal
little toenail says I cannot wrap my
head around
time dilation can you please explain it
to me and I'm like who knew little
toenail had a head
okay fine
you scratching the bottom of the barrel
for that one I don't know I'm just
saying some something's going on with
that foot if the foot is doing that
thing yeah that's right what's the big
toe thing what is the big toe thinking
it's no toenail is worried about time
dilation
what the hell is big toe
so here's the thing we have two
coordinates that Define us where we are
in space and where we are in time
you can if you sit your butt in one
place you were moving forward in time
but your stationary in space okay
if you
our speed of light
you are moving forward in space but
you're stationary in time
time does not tick
for light
if you are anything in between those two
extremes
there'll be a combination of your space
changing and your time changing
the rate at which time ticks
because both of those matter to figure
out where everything is and where it's
going in the universe
so you can think of it as two axes a
space axis and a Time axis and light
moves along the uh the space axis okay
and you if again if you if you are
sitting there not moving at all you move
perfectly along the time axis you can
find other places in that chart
where space and time are moving at
various rates relative to each other
okay
and so the GPS satellites for example
they are in a different place they're
farther away from Earth's gravity so
their space-time diagram means time
ticks more slowly for them than it does
for us
so when they tell you what time it is we
have to pre-correct it with an
einsteinian equation so that the time
you get on Earth's surface matches what
everybody else is using it's amazing
it's completely amazing that's right
so cool that is so cool so trippy and I
actually didn't even get The Nobel Prize
for that he got it for much lesser work
yeah had they totally done his Nobel
Prize some some justice he would have
had like eight Nobel prizes yeah because
I mean yeah figuring out that time ticks
more slowly correct is you know I mean
that's beyond mind-blowing that is
beyond that is a tectonic perspective
shift on the entire universe itself yes
it is Einstein changed the cosmic
perspective
amazing all right I feel so
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
no all right oh man I love that so much
I can never get enough of that all right
here we go don't confuse being stupid
and not knowing with being curious and
eager to find out
uh can I be both and no no I'm not
giving you that
I have more confidence in you okay good
all right this is uh
medeiro ma uh oh Maddie Rose Madden okay
Maddie Rose Madden from Tick Tock okay
check this out
you're getting in the middle of uh
perhaps a spousal argument here uh-oh
okay just letting you know right now all
right do we leave in or on the earth my
husband says that we live in the Earth
because of the atmosphere I say we live
on the earth because the Earth's
atmosphere is on the Earth yeah
okay all right what do we what do we got
here I mean all right I gotta settle
this you gotta settle this now I'm gonna
settle this all right you must bring
peace to this home all right you ready
okay before 1970. if you no before 1968
if you said draw Earth
people would draw a globe and and they
would draw oceans and they draw the
continents correct
nobody Drew clouds that's right take a
look at any old image of Earth there are
no clouds on it not even Star Trek which
should have known better they're
um you know how does it begin uh space
the final frontier These Are the Voyages
and you see that it it's and you see
Earth in the background there's no
clouds on it so no one thought about
our atmosphere as something fundamental
to the identity of Earth until 1968 with
Apollo 8 went to the Moon looked back
took a picture of the Earth and there it
was as only nature intended you to see
it with oceans land and clouds
do you realize after 1968 that was
December 68 there was legislation to
create and was ultimately signed a year
and a half later the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration Noah
right before then no one had connected
the oceans and the air before hadn't
been done yet there were atmosphere
people and there were ocean people and
you had land people and then you had
people studying lights and so the other
geologists in the Bible now we find that
life is thriving throughout the Earth on
rocks in down through the crust of the
earth and that oceans interact with the
Sur with our land masses changing their
shapes and and and the ACT where does
the ocean where does the atmosphere get
its water further it gets it from the
ocean this is an entire system
so since then nobody draws Earth without
clouds
so I declare
by authority vested in Me by the
universe and most specifically by The
Cosmic perspective that if someone wants
to say that living on Earth's surface
beneath
15 pounds per square inch of atmospheric
Mass if they want to say we live in the
Earth
I'm all for it oh
otherwise you'd have to say Earth does
not include the atmosphere and I'm not
prepared to do that oh
so we do but I think I think I I
Justified it right I didn't say we have
my opinion no so now just to fight about
it here's why it makes sense and by the
way Earth's atmosphere is so thin
Earth's atmosphere is to Earth
as the skin of an apple is to the Apple
that's just terrible
I mean the way we treat the atmosphere
that's why I say it's terrible oh yeah
yeah right right you think you think
you're in the bottom of a large ocean no
you're at the bottom of a really skinny
skinny thing and it's just because
you're little that it looks big right
but when you're big it looks little
wow there it is so we live in Earth
people
in Earth yeah which makes sense because
this is a spaceship hurling through
space correct so we would you wouldn't
travel on a spaceship you travel in a
spaceship yes correct as as George
Carlin clearly noted where he gets you
might be getting on the plane he's
getting in the plane yeah I didn't I
never heard that you never heard that oh
that's in his airplane segment yeah okay
I like it all right okay look at that
sorry Maddie Rose Madden you're gonna be
mad when you hear this but you know like
I got another one so do you live in a
city or on a city
well see I live in a city no no you see
the city has a grid and you you're
standing on the grid of the city right
yeah you're in three dimensions if you
were flat and you cross the border of
the city you'd be in the city
but you stand up above this you're on
the city okay I'm down to be on the city
what do you think of that I'm on the
town baby without it I'm all alone all
right all right that sounds good give me
one more
how about uh it's Sasha 2020 from Tick
Tock says this
okay
um
are there time machines now specifically
I I'm taking this question seriously
because I've heard you speak to this
um and then she's and then a second
question
do you think people will be able to time
travel
so they're okay I have an answer for
that and I can answer both when we come
back from the break oh oh okay we're
done with our second segment of cosmic
queries back to school edition stuff you
wanted to learn in school and didn't or
want to put back in the curriculum so
others can how about that uh when we
come back more of cosmic queries
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries back
to school edition reaching out beyond
our patreon course supporters to others
who might enjoy this and become a
supporter as well and Chuck you left off
someone who who is it at that it's us in
2020. it's Sasha 2020. yeah she asked a
compound question but it's two separate
questions but I are there time are there
um are there time machines okay I'm old
enough perhaps you chucked two no you're
not I just remembered how old you are
I'm old enough to remember there was a
TV show called Time Tunnel where okay it
was the 1970s and the scientist invented
this tunnel and you walk in you can
travel back in time clearly something
goes wrong otherwise it wouldn't be a TV
show so they get lost in time and they
bouncing back in different times so the
the pilot episode guess where they went
uh Camden New Jersey no
they went back to the Titanic of course
okay and for a while there people it
might be because of that show people
were interviewed where would you go want
to go the most they said I want to go
back to the Titanic so we have evidence
that at some point time machines are
invented because all those people went
back to the time Titanic and they were
too heavy for the Titanic and that's
right
that's what sunk the Titanic all of the
time travelers who went back to the
Titanic to see it sink that's what
actually sunk the Titanic so so the real
question is if their time oh Stephen
Hawking held a party
okay for all time travelers of the
future
and he said if you're a time traveler we
will expect you to show up right in
front of me and if he summons you that
you got to show up right because it's
Stephen Hawking that's Stephen Hawking
are you sitting there in his wheelchair
and everybody's around and they got an
open some and nobody appears
foreign
so that could mean
that a time machine will never be
invented in the future
or it's invented but there's a law of
physics that prevents you
from going back in time just because of
the risks involved
the risk now in The Terminator what did
he do
um well he basically had to save his son
wait no no no no he had to he had to
make sure the leader of the Chuck what
what country are are you American are
you no he had to he had to make sure the
person who led the revolution Against
the Machine was never born he has to
make sure he never exists oh the
Terminator I thought you meant the guy
that was sent back to
to help Sarah Connor yeah but you're
talking about the Terminator itself he
went back to kill John Connor before he
was born correct and and so doing you
kill the mother right okay and so this
is so violent though it's so violent all
you have to do is prevent the mother
from meeting the man who she had sex
with to make Tom Connor to create junk
that's all you have to do you have to
kill everybody but that's what made
Terminator so great the guy that he sent
back to protect her ended up being John
Connor's Dad okay so if the Terminator
never went back to kill John Connor John
Connor would have never been born in the
first place because the Terminator was
really like the Tinder for John Connor
and Sarah Connor so the Terminator is a
Time idiot right he just basically got
to figure that out he made them he made
that happen right so point is
there could be some as Hawking suggested
a time travel conjecture that says you
can't travel back in time but if you do
you'll have no access to any world line
that you ever touched because if you if
you somehow trip up your grandmother
then your grand
your mother is never born or your
father's never born and then you're
never born and then you would not have
been alive to go back to trip them up so
and the Terminator version of that is
you kill everybody right right so anyhow
uh so yeah no we think no
there you go we think no no no time
machine all right here is a great
question and it's from havers X by the
way in the in the science March by the
way if scientists have to March
that look I should be worried you should
be worried okay yeah am I right here
yeah without a doubt like if nerds are
go on the March right so I'm seriously
wrong with with Society okay so when
Nerds run amok Society has gone really
in a toilet that's not what I said but
fine but they run amok
so one of them held a poster that said
an enchant what do we want time machine
when do we want it it doesn't matter
right
that's funny okay all right I like that
all right here we go
this is heyverse dot X from Instagram
and save her spell that
h-a-y-b-e-r-s-e hey verse habers wow
okay yeah like the universe but just hey
verse all right yeah so um it says
this is a good one
as quickly and succinctly as possible
please explain quantum physics in a
simple way a heck I can do so this from
Tick Tock uh Instagram Instagram oh yeah
because if it's tick tock and he's
saying explain it quickly and simply
that's a Tick-Tock virus that he's got
right right right everything's got to be
fast and and so all I can say is as you
look to smaller and smaller things in
the universe whole other laws that
dictate what they do and how they do it
kick in
and so quantum physics is the theory of
the small
that describes atoms molecules subatomic
particles and the as if you get larger
and larger those laws still apply but
they get averaged out and we get what's
called classical physics
so we needed to understand atoms and
molecules and there is no information
technology
the store The Creation storage and
retrieval of information there is no I.T
without an exploitation of the quantum
so it's not just some idle curiosity
from bone-headed you know pointy-headed
physicists it's a fundamental part of
what we consider modern civilization
there you go yeah what are you doing
glue on your laws don't apply to me
let's go let's uh let's do a lightning
Round Here We Go all right lightening it
up lightning round I answering sound
bites okay go uh Nico 2K7 says this from
Instagram uh why I see why do I see
myself inverted when I look in the
mirror
I hope you're not inverted but you you
swap left and right yeah if you're
upside down in America upside down buddy
the reason is is because you're in an
alternate universe no no actually
there's a curvature you can give to the
mirror where you are in fact upside down
so the beauty mirrors if you back up
away from them you'll see yourself
upside down in them so so if yeah if
you're if you're upside down in a mirror
you have a it's a fun house mirror but
otherwise you are reflected left and
right but not top to bottom because what
what's actually happening is you are
being reflected through a line
that goes through the center of your
body
so your nose gets reflected to the other
side of your nose your cheeks go to the
other side and everything starts here
and moves through the mirror and shows
up on the other side
so reflection is not what you think it
is it's not just simply let's swap left
and right you're actually recreating
yourself through the mirror with these
reflections
so that's why look at that and by the
way that reflection has a whole life of
its own and when you walk away from a
mirror it walks away to go do stuff that
you don't even know anything about and
you'll get blamed for it
so you got it all right here we go
um
srivasta
okay whatever no I want to hear the
person's last name
h-a-r-s-h-a-r-j harsharaj okay that
wasn't that hard no it was it it wasn't
says this uh from where
from Instagram and this is all it says
maybe you'll get it
time travel paradoxes
so the funny thing about paradoxes is
that there aren't any
if the Paradox is a paradox to you
because you haven't really calculated it
correctly the time travel Paradox is I
send you off and you're moving at a high
speed and I see that your time is
ticking slowly
whereas you don't know that because
you're it's just your clock and your
heart rate and as far as you're
concerned everything is normal but you
see me on Earth
receding away from you with my time
ticking slowly
so how can we both see each other's time
ticking slowly
okay that's called that's called it's
called the twin paradox if you want to
you send off a twin how does that twin
you sent off become younger than you
when they look back at you and time is
moving more slowly for you as well it's
because
when you come back you lose that effect
so I can send you away but when you slow
down turn around and come back
that changes your relationship to me in
the universe you're the one that's
accelerating not not I
in this and the one who's accelerating
will feel the effects of the of of of
the time dilation relative to me
and so but if you just kept going I
would think your time would slow down
forever just as you would think my time
had slowed down so it's a matter of do
you slow down turn around and come back
and to do so you decelerated and
accelerated and that changes the game
there you have it all right that was a
that was a very good that wasn't very
very sound biting but well okay it's a
very good explanation though let's keep
trying that's how it goes all right
here's another one this is Anton uh-huh
Anthony Spina says this
uh from Instagram
please explain nuclear energy
uh quickly and well
[Laughter]
I love it no room for me to mess up here
right right right
uh so
um energy is has something it is an
entity that has the capacity to do work
okay that's basically the definition of
energy you can store the energy to do
work later okay and that's where you
have uh like if you have a hot pack
if you have a hot pack and it's just
room temperature until you sprain your
knee and then at the at the softball
game they they slap it on the ground and
shake it and and bake it I mean shake it
and jiggle it that releases chemical
energy that had been bound into the
molecules themselves
that's an that's chemical energy well
inside the nucleus there's also energy
if you break apart some nuclei it'll
release energy and that's all nuclear
energy is the energy contained in a
nucleus as opposed to a a chemical
energy which is the energy contained in
the molecules right so there you go it's
simple it's really not that complicated
it's right that's it that's it that's
really I mean that's
hey quickly and well that was it quickly
and well baby all right here we go uh
this is Larry uh 260 2279 at Instagram
says does every Star belong to a Galaxy
or are there also lonely Stars okay we
have a word for something called
Vagabond Stars yeah and if they're
Vagabond Stars
um could also be Vagabond planets we
think some planets when they're trying
to form in their star system get ejected
and then they wander through space
basically homeless all right but many
planets have interior heat like we do
so if you have a source of heat you
might be able to still sustain life even
though you're not near any stars at all
so that's an interesting side light
about Vagabond planets but Vagabond
Stars uh sure in fact one of my early
research projects was on that very topic
they're called Intergalactic supernovae
so these were stars that would be kicked
out of their host Galaxy and then
explode and you'd see them exploding far
away from their Brethren and they had no
business being that far out so as far as
we know yes there are there could be
very many
as well
I don't need y'all anyway I've been
kicked out a better galaxies than this
Chuck you sound like you've actually had
to say that in real life at one point
that came out so smoothly and quickly
yeah that was all I can say was well
rehearsed that
I've kicked out of better joints all
right all right here we go
um this is Shane Vinnie and Shane Vinnie
says this could the Big Bang or big bang
type events occur regularly
I we think in the Multiverse yes
they were just one of multiple bangs
that are happening all the time
so regularly on that scale yes there's
nothing stopping it because of what the
the powers of the Multiverse actually
are they're a universe birthing machine
and so uh yeah but in terms of our own
Universe not so much no we don't think
that's what's going on and then he says
or she says uh or they say white holes
Maybe
white holds for what does this follow-on
to that yes so could could the Big Bang
what I I'm not sure what a white yeah
well we thought okay for a while you
know when whitehall's got discovered
they're like the mathematical opposite
of a black hole all right you notice
like you know it's like so uh if I say
what's
3 squared what would you tell me uh six
nine
let's try that again Chuck
fifth grade math what if what's three
squared three times three no nine okay
so now we say what's the square root of
nine
well three three of course but it's also
negative three that's right because
negative three times negative is also
nine nine when you do the equations for
a black hole there's a second solution
and a so it's like the the opposite
solution to a black hole black holes eat
everything white holes emit everything
so we calculated what these should look
like in the universe looked around and
we didn't find a lick of them yeah so
but it would be cool if white holes were
birthing universes but we have no real
evidence of that now what white holes do
is they use black holes to do all their
work
and then they might colonize the
universe but
[Music]
[Laughter]
do not write people
people that was fun
that was fun damn dude you better not
write and I'm serious they're called
jokes no I'll say it I'll say uh
everyone Chuck still has he's got he's
got a black thing going on
you can't shake it I can't shake it we
had we had a show on on on contagious
diseases and we talk about the black
plague and Chuck said why everything bad
gotta be black okay that's right he's
got to be the black plague Nothing Gets
By Chuck all right so we need you to
highlight that in almost every case
Chuck we got to call it quits we got
some questions yeah that was good let's
do that again yeah it was a lot of fun
right thank you all from Tick Tock and
Instagram the rest of our our uh our
sand platforms and we're happy to serve
you and thanks for sending in your
questions uh Chuck always good to have
you man always a pleasure this has been
Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson here we
are a personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
[Music]
thank you